Hey guys,
just a quick bumper before we start this video over on the discord server,
and you'll find a link down in the description, but over on the discord server,
we are looking for more moderators are just core servers grown to about 6,200
people. It's nuts. We need more moderators for the discord.
So if you are interested head over to the discord server and look for the
moderator application channel,
and you'll see the kinds of questions that we're asking, uh,
if you need some help with that just below that channel is the moderator
application help channel.
And that'll basically walk you through the process and tell you why we're asking
the kinds of questions that we're asking and what it is that we're looking for
in moderators. So make sure you guys go check that out and, uh, yeah,
let's begin. What's going on guys.
This is Rob and we are picking up with the aftermath to joker war and this kind
of start of a whole new Batman and Mrs. Cool. If I'm being honest with you guys,
I love this, this new direction that DC's taking Batman in.
And if I'm being honest,
I kind of feel like it's a long time coming to be honest with you guys and you
guys will see what I mean by the time we get to the end of this.
But initially this,
this kind of picks up with a bit of musing on behalf of Bruce Wayne,
right in the aftermath of everything that's going on.
It's a little bit amusing here and he talks about how the way things used to be
right back in the day. And when I say back in the day,
I mean for quite some time in DC comics,
really since like the introduction of Batman in the very early days in the sense
that when we had commissioner Gordon,
when we had the introduction of the bat signal,
when you had Alfred that things kind of follow this pattern that Bruce Wayne
would begin his night, you know, as Batman,
he put on his Clover and Cal he'd go out into the city and then like the bat
signal might come up. Right. And that was just kind of an indicator of, Hey,
things are popping off, come and see me. Uh, commissioner Gordon would say that,
you know, come and see me.
And I'll kind of give you the skinny on what's happening throughout Gotham as a
whole. Now, once Bruce Wayne was given this rundown,
it'd be left to him to decide which one needed the most attention basically.
Right? And once you narrow that down, you kind of investigate the various clues.
Somehow sometimes you would do this with Robin.
Other times you would do it by himself. He'd have Alfred in his ear,
kind of giving him some advice. And, and, you know, as an outside perspective,
uh, he'd get back to the bat cave.
Alfred would basically push him to eat or drink something,
but Batman would always have this idea of if I stay here and investigate long
enough, I can kind of put the clues together and I can solve this case.
And that was the form and function by which everything in Gotham city worked and
then seemingly over the course of a single night or over the course of an
exceedingly short period of time, all that went away, Alfred died,
commissioner Gordon's out of the picture,
the joker who managed to successfully take over Gotham city.
Batman's lost pretty much all of his resources, right?
It's kind of just him and a lot of this, this discussion that he has really,
really comes from Selena Kyle. And that's when she's kind of like,
I can see that look on your face. It drives, it drives me insane. I hate it.
It's that you've made a decision and it's going to change both of our lives and
it's the right decision to make. But you know,
that it's going to suck in terms of this decision. And my initial thought was,
Batman's calling it off, right? He's, he's basically telling Selena,
like we're no longer together anymore.
The reality of this is he basically kind of says joker was right.
I've been doing this, I've been doing this all wrong for a very long time.
And that's true, right? That man's been doing this wrong for a very,
very lengthy amount of time. Right? And, and the way this is the,
the reason why this kind of comes out,
picks up about a week ago and we basically end up picking up grifter.
And now the reality is a grifter is a character.
I don't really know a whole lot about,
I know enough to know that he comes from the WildStorm imprint,
which was created by, uh, by Jim Lee and Brandon Choi back in the day,
back in the nineties.
And he was part of a group called international operations.
I think it was kind of like an espionage spy team WildStorm was largely its own
universe. It was just kind of out there doing its own thing and the aftermath of
flashpoint and the launch of the new 52 WildStorm became part of the main DC
line of comics. But that's really all I know about grifter. And honestly,
I don't really care that much to know anything more about him.
He's not interesting to me.
I don't really care much about his character for the longer shorter for the sake
of this video. Since you know,
this channel really is designed to educate you guys.
The nature of grifter is such that he has powers in so far as,
as telekinetic abilities. He's exceedingly fast. He's a great con artist, right?
He was, uh, he was, uh, uh,
a member of the U S military special ops team or group or whatever you want to
call it before he deserted and became a con man effectively,
he was at one point involved with a group of aliens called Damon nights or
demonized. I'm not a hundred percent sure how to pronounce that.
The basically tried to possess him to take over his physical form. Uh,
he ended up escaping. And then for the most part,
he's just kind of been somewhat of a wonder.
I think it really more of just kind of like a hired gun, like a mercenary,
but in this particular instance here,
he's basically working as a bodyguard for Lucius Fox right now.
Batman is aware of who grifter is. The fight between them is really interesting.
And if anything, I think it's really one of these attempts by DC to say,
Hey guys, like look at this guy grifter, you know, he's,
he's pretty interesting. Um, I don't think anybody's really buying it, but, uh,
he's, he's capable enough to where he can kind of fight Batman to a standstill,
but he's basically been hired as a bodyguard by Lucius Fox.
And the reason for this is as part of the hold over with regards to joker Wark,
Lucius Fox is still the person in possession of Batman's wealth, right.
Of Bruce Wayne's wealth and really kind of the guy running Wayne enterprises now
in, in the videos that we do,
where we do like a character explanation or team explanation or something like
that, we'll talk about stories that happen over the course of a characters,
publication history that basically changes things up.
The kind of initiates a huge status quo. That's what this is, right?
This is a massive status quo change for Batman.
That's what you guys are literally reading history in real time.
And this particular instance,
rifles you guys who bought the book who are reading it right now,
you're reading through history like a huge history change in real time,
how long it lasts. We don't really know,
but the idea behind this is that with Lucius Fox,
more or less kind of running the show here effectively being a billionaire,
there's a few things going on the first is that he still Harbor some ill will
towards Batman in the sense that everything that happened with joker Wark, uh,
you know, the,
the way that he was infected by joker toxin and all that kind of stuff,
the experiences left him largely with some measure of PTSD. Now,
the other part of that is we kind of get this indication that punchline still
around, cause she's kind of out there talking to the press and things like that.
That was DC teasing us with an idea of punchlines mini series or maybe her
ongoing series. I'm not really sure,
but the other part of that is you still have clown Hunter and clown Hunter is
still basically going through tracking down members who were part of jokers
gang, and then taking them out where he finds them. Now,
the reason why this matters is because in the sure,
math of joker war in the fall of the joker,
those individuals who were part of his army vanished because their leader was
effectively gone, their, their chance of success, right? Their chance of,
of kind of having the world as they want.
I wanted it to be actually coming to fruition was gone, right?
So it was basically you guys lost. And in that instance, you know, in that case,
they basically took off and they, they down, right? They,
they ended up basically kind of going underground.
And that's an important distinction to understand here.
There's a difference between quitting and just going to a place where you can't
be detected.
And that's basically what was happening here for the jokers army in terms of
putting on the mask and going on,
going out every night and doing things that's over, right?
They don't really do that anymore. Instead they meet underground.
They meet in places that are not easily found and then plot or plan accordingly.
Now the joker still out there. And as far as we're aware,
the joker doesn't really have any money Walnut with his own gang.
Because as we know, as the reader,
the joker doesn't really care about those guys.
They believe the joker cares and they hope the joker cares,
but the joker doesn't really care about them. They were cannon fodder, right?
They were a means to achieve an end.
Now whether or not they were intelligent enough to realize that is a wholly
different beast. And in times of desperation,
people believe what they want to believe.
And what ended up happening here is you had people who wanted things to be a
certain way, the joker represented that way.
And ultimately they kind of tied the two together of their own volition.
The joker saying things I like, and the joker is espousing ideologies.
I agree with therefore the joker agrees with me,
the joker likes me and results of that is they ended up kind of becoming the
people that they were becoming. Now, the joker basically kind of falling joker,
having been defeated, or at least a scheme ending,
kind of puts them in a position to where it's will the joker still out there.
The joker will save us. You know, I'm, I'm kind of making some assumptions here,
but you know, it's, it's, it's interesting.
It basically means a Joker's army is not Holy dead, albeit very much, you know,
much smaller than it used to be.
But the long and short of this is that there are some major things going on with
Bruce Wayne and especially Wayne man, Wayne, Wayne enterprises,
and Lucius Fox that Lucius Fox to a degree kind of enjoys the idea of it,
having all this wealth. You know, he goes, as far as to say,
I'm not going to lie, lie to you and say that like, it's fine. You know, that,
that, that I want this money doesn't benefit me. It does. It benefits me.
It benefits my family. That's the truth of the matter, right?
Having these funds at my disposal,
but understand that Wayne enterprises is looking to force you out, right?
Like you are a member of the board,
but they're looking to basically give you like a huge chunk of change.
Let you just kind of draw income seemingly for the rest of your life.
And then you go away.
Now you basically end up stepping down from Wayne enterprises as part of the
board. You have no decision making ability anymore. More so than that,
the reason why is because the heat's on to you. But the governor,
I mean is looking at you.
One of the big things that came out of joker war was how,
how Bruce Wayne was spending his money off shore counts,
different things like that.
And so the IRS and the financial sector of the federal government, right?
So seemingly the secret service,
if there's any indication of fraud on a massive level of being invoked,
they're looking into Bruce Wayne. And so the more he's in the public eye,
the more heat and scrutiny he draws on the Wayne enterprises.
And so it's best for business that Bruce Wayne stepped down. And that's the,
one of the big reasons why Lucius Fox is kind of holding onto this money.
The other part of that is that the notion that the public perception out there,
that Wayne,
as a person who was potentially engaging in embezzlement or at the very least
tax fraud, right? Like, you know, or,
or even just dodging taxes is not good for the public,
for public perception of Wayne enterprises.
And so one of the other reasons why they want him to step down and so that they
can rebrand, right? They can rebrand Wayne enterprises, right? It's all new,
all different Wayne enterprises or something like that.
Hopefully not as bad as what Marvel did and you know,
in the aftermath of secret Wars,
but the whole point behind that is they're looking literally distance themselves
from Bruce Wayne. And so the important thing behind this,
and the reason why this matters is that Bruce Wayne cannot operate as Batman.
The way he's done in the past,
which is to say with a unlimited checkbook and all the high-tech gadgetry in the
world, that at the end,
Batman is going to have to operate on the most basic level.
There's no high-tech gadgetry.
There's no super advanced Batmobile tools with all the resources in the world
that just come off of some endless supply chain.
It doesn't work that way anymore. That he's got a Batmobile.
If the Batmobile breaks down, he's got to fix it.
And there's a couple of reasons for why this is happening.
The first is because at this point,
it's obvious DC's bringing Batman comics more in line with Robert Pattinson's
Batman film.
The other part of this is because we've seen this happen before the most notable
instance came in 1969 during the Frank Robinson Edmund Hamilton era with Batman
number 217.
And this was a point where Dick Grayson had basically left to go to college.
And the result of this is that, uh,
Bruce Wayne actually ended up leaving Wayne Manor and taking up residence in the
city of Gotham.
And the reason why that's important is because what you end up having here is
this conversation between himself and Selena Kyle, where he says,
that's what I want to do. Now. One of the,
one of the little moments that comes out of this,
this is really more of a plot point that'll become important later on is that
when Bruce Wayne ends up leaving, leaving Lucius fought, right,
leaving that office, he tells grifter, like send a message to your boss, right?
Until you send a message, delicious Fox, tell him I know what halo is.
And basically I'm watching, it looks like it's, you know,
some kind of little bit of an underground thing,
some kind of plot point that we'll see later on down the line,
but kind of picking back up with Bruce Wayne and Selena Kyle. Again,
he basically says I'm going to move into the city itself.
And that's what he did in the aftermath. Really with Batman 217,
he ended up moving into a penthouse inside Gotham city.
And that was designed more for him to be closer to the ground, to be more,
more direct. The, the issue with this is that in the aftermath of that,
he ended up deciding that being so close to the city was not the best idea
because it was too easy for people to pick up and distinguish the fact that
Bruce Wayne was Batman, right. They were seeing him every day.
People could find a way to break in different things like that.
And putting the pieces together was seemingly just too easy.
So it didn't last all that long. And I would say,
if this does remain a mainstay for James Kenyans run, once you leave,
he'll go back to Wayne Manor, right?
And then we'll probably find some way in which, you know,
Alfred comes back probably using the Lazarus pits, you know, who really knows,
but the, the, the whole point behind this is that he basically says like,
there's a brownstone there that I own.
And I didn't even realize that I owned it.
So I'm certainly going to move into it. I'm not going to live across the bridge.
I'm going to live inside the city that I want to protect. So again,
kind of reiterating what we've seen happen in years past when it came to Batman.
The funny thing about this is that he had actually considered the idea of Selena
Kyle kind of renaming herself, right?
Like creating a new identity and her working alongside Bruce Wayne.
The issue with this is that with Selena Kyle and Bruce Wayne spending time
together, and then Catwoman and Batman hanging out together,
people would have put the pieces together like that.
They would have done it so quick. And they would have said,
Bruce Wayne is Selena, Kyla hanging out all the time.
Batman and Catwoman are fighting crime together all the time is Bruce Wayne,
Selena Kyle Batman, and Catwoman.
Somebody somewhere would have figured that out. Right.
The funny thing about this though, is a Selena.
Kyle had the reverse idea that Bruce Wayne could just run off with her. Now,
of course, Bruce's response is I can't do that. And that's true, right?
How's DC going to publish Batman comics. If Bruce, Wayne's not Batman,
it doesn't work.
Nobody wants to read a Batman comic where Bruce Wayne is not Batman for like 10
years for a short amount of time. Sure. Right?
Like the whole aftermath of final crisis, you know,
where like Dick Grayson was Batman for a time. And Damian Wayne was Robin shirt.
That's interesting. The aftermath of Batman nightfall. Sure.
But in terms of like 2030, that like Bruce Wayne is still not Batman.
People don't want that. People want Bruce Wayne to be Batman forever. Right.
It's just kind of the way things are. So we come up with fans are,
we do not like change. And so as one of these things, where,
where Bruce Wayne basically, and even something that, uh,
Selena Kyle basically say like,
we need to kind of get ourselves re-grounded right. Like we need to,
we need to reground ourselves.
And so what's interesting about this is like you Selina. Kyle's like,
we'll take one year, basically one year apart,
one year for them to figure things out, to get them, uh, get things grounded,
to get themselves sorted out. And then at the end of that one year,
basically reconcile,
consolidate and see whether or not they can move forward together.
And so where you kind of ended up getting as them basically going to the
brownstone of Bruce Wayne and knocking boots, right? I mean,
there's no apartment, no furniture in there.
Let's lean to cause like who needs furniture? But nonetheless, it's,
it's a it's it's, it's interesting. This is the whole new Batman, right?
It's DC taking Batman back to the way he was back during the sixties and the
seventies where he had some semblance of high-tech gadgetry,
but Batman comics were largely reliant on Bruce Wayne's intuition, right?
His intelligence, his detective skills,
and some measure of super advanced gadgetry. But in recent years,
I would say Batman comics have largely focused and shifted their focus to like
Bruce Wayne, being able to achieve his goals, using like super high tech stuff.
And I'm excited to read comics where it's just Batman and his intellect.
I'm excited to read that it's a throwback to the, to the comment,
to the Batman comics of yesteryear. And I'm looking forward to it a lot.
So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain,
make sure you guys at the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light.
I will catch you all later.
Wow.
[inaudible].